good evening everyone welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Kerri
Douglas and I'm the press secretary at
the Swiss Embassy and I'm also a member
of the book and author rap committee
here at the National Press Club I'm
really pleased to introduce you to you
this evening mr. Anthony Sampson who has
just recently published the book Mandela
the authorized biography but first I'd
like to just share with you some details
of some upcoming book wrap committee
events that are coming up here at the
Press Club first we have our Elle Stein
will join us for our first children's
book wrap this Saturday and the book has
nightmare hour then next week at the
National Press Club is sponsoring the
Australian experience 1999 on Wednesday
next week we'll we will host an
Australian literature book rap featuring
Thomas Keneally among four other
contemporary authors then on September
23rd Susan Faludi will talk about her
new book stiffed the betrayal of the
American man John Kenneth Galbraith will
join us on October 5th to talk about his
book name-dropping on October 20th
JK Rowling will be here for her latest
book Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban and then on October 26 we have
Michael Lewis who will discuss his book
the new new thing a Silicon Valley story
so for more information on some of those
events you can pick up the Flyers just
right outside the door there so now
let's get to what we're here for this
evening mr. Sampson and the book is
Nelson Mandela the authorized biography
mr. Sampson has a reputation of being
very keen an astute journalist who works
who knows how to smell a story and then
deliver a book just as the story becomes
headline news mr. Sampson has excellent
timing as recognized by the release of
seven sisters during the oil crisis and
moneylenders during the third world debt
crisis
now we have something special a book
that reveals mr. Sampson's passion for
South Africa and his respect for a
remarkable leader who has changed the
course of South African history it is
clear mr. Samson caught the bug when he
was editor of drum magazine in 1951 and
also when he gave a clenched fist salute
to mr. Mandela during the trial in 1964
mr. Samson is also known mr. Mandela for
almost 50 years
Mandela the authorized biography is
extensive insightful and vibrant Samson
delivers a perspective of Mandela who
has overcome many obstacles to achieve
the moral success necessary to ensure
the future of South Africa Mandela is
the story of a man of courage who breaks
the system of apartheid with
determination and political astuteness
to this day Mandela greets people with a
gentleness in serenity even after 27
years in prison before he entered prison
in 1964 at his trial in bateria Mandela
closed his defence statement with
something I thought we should consider
during my lifetime I have dedicated
myself to this struggle of the African
people I have fought against white
domination and I have fought against
black domination I have cherished the
ideal of a democratic and free society
in which all persons live together in
harmony and with equal opportunities it
is an ideal which I hope to live for and
to achieve but if needs be it is an
ideal for which I am prepared to die
Mandela the authorized biography is the
story of his achievement mr. Samson
thank you very much and thank you for
braving the hurricane we're not used to
hurricanes in Europe and I flew over
from London last night wondering exactly
what I was coming into but it's very
nice to be here in the eye of the storm
in every every sense but I would like if
I could to share with you one or two of
my thoughts really having finished the
book and reflections that come so often
as they do come after you've written the
last paragraphs which sometimes more
interesting than what you've actually
written but of course I'd very much
appreciate the discussion afterwards so
that we can have more of a seminar and
less of a lecture but in particular I
wanted to discuss the what to me is the
most fascinating part of Mandela's
career which is that what he when it
tells us about the nature of leadership
not just in South Africa or in Africa
but generally around the world because
of course he has achieved I suppose a
kind of importance and a kind of magic
as an icon which very few other leaders
at the moment have achieved at all and
it's difficult I find it difficult
writing in the book when you have such a
dazzling image with such magic
associated with it to see clearly behind
it it's rather like facing a car with
the headlights full on you can only
barely make out the actual shape that is
behind it and it is of course always
difficult as a biographer particularly
as an old friend with access to your
subject it's difficult always to be
entirely uninfluenced by that magic
yourself but when I discussed with him
writing the book and he told me to my
great pride that he thought I was the
ideal person to write it I did tell him
that I wanted to be sure that I could
make my own judgments
I wanted to be sure the facts that
wanted him to read the manuscript but
that I wanted to have independent
judgments and he must not regard those
as being in any way his responsibility
and he told me then that he very much
hoped that I would be independent
he said I'm no angel I'm not a saint and
I wanted to be depicted as an ordinary
man with human weaknesses which of
course a lot of people say the first
place but no nature today face up to
when they see their as weaknesses
written about but he was wonderfully
helpful he did read through the whole
manuscript he made fascinating aids in
the margin which I treasure and apart
from just one or two disputes he was
quite content for me to make some
judgments which I thought he would find
very sensitive and difficult to accept
and of course as your mansion to have
the chance to write about a living
person who is already a historical
figure and then to be able to talk to
that figure yourself is a very unusual
privilege I sometimes felt I was as it
were like a historian of the French
Revolution who was suddenly able to talk
to Robespierre and Don to themselves and
to us what they really thought about
events and it was them to me the
combination of the documents the
extraordinary range of historical
information that I had access to with
the chance to talk to Mandela and his
colleagues about what they thought
happened which was the most fascinating
part of the challenge but in the book
I've tried to share the man behind the
myth and to also to trace the
relationship between the man and the
myth because of course the mythology who
was so powerful that inevitably it
itself reacted on the person and that's
a problem that many politicians face but
then nationally solve how do you
actually preserve an element of reality
in yourself when you are faced with that
degree of Mythology and often worship
around you of course the mythology was
much greater far greater because of the
fact that he'd spent 20
years in prison that itself of course
gave I can't a fairy tale element to the
story that is why I think Mandela is a
figure of fascination not a need to
anybody interested in politics but quite
ordinary children who see him as almost
a character from a fairy tale
he's the prisoner in the dungeon who
comes out to become becomes a prince
it's part of a long history of heroism
and of course that process of mythology
began very much while he was still in
prison and many of you will remember the
time in the 80s when the the publicity
around Mandela built up throughout that
decade how the image of Mandela in the
world seemed so a superhuman name
amazing that it was hard to equate it to
any real person because you he was
thought to be so all-powerful and so
extraordinary that he didn't seem like
any person that one knew or understood
let alone a politician who has after all
that in particular weaknesses but it was
for that reason that I find that task of
the biography particularly fascinating
because I did have the wonderful good
luck to have known him before he went to
prison and to me the most interesting
challenge of the story was to portray
Mandela before and after and then to see
the prison part of the story in that
perspective and to see how far that
changed him I had the very odd
experience of having as a young man just
down from Oxford of gay being invited
out to South Africa by a friend to edit
this new magazine called drum in
Johannesburg now nothing about either
Africa or journalism but I was then
right in the midst of this world of
black Johannesburg quickly became editor
of the magazine and found myself knowing
quite well
maestra Nellie
all the black writers but more important
of course the young black politicians
who were just then starting their career
as militant campaigners against
apartheid which only just been
instituted as a policy when I first went
out now I would like to be able to say
that I'd always know when I met Mandela
in 51 that he was going to be the leader
in South Africa I'd like to say that I
had perceived immediately his unusual
qualities in fact I didn't I recall very
clearly how although he was impressive
courageous militant very fine-looking I
thought he was a showman I thought he
was too much of a showman to be a rail
leader he was a magnificent chairman he
had this superb presence tall strong
with a bright white smile and great
charm very articulate but it seemed to
me that that was a kind of showbiz smile
he looked like so many smiles at her
toothpaste smile and it wasn't to me
altogether convincing he was interesting
but his speeches always seem to be
rather formal with quite a lot of
cliches and there was a kind of
militancy about him that I rather
distrusted he had to be restrained by
some of his colleagues and you sometimes
felt he was spoiling for a fight in fact
he was rather as historically as for
instance Teddy Roosevelt must have
appeared in this country in its more
militant phases or indeed Winston
Churchill before the Second World War
both of whom were inclined to be
spoiling for fights well of course I was
entirely wrong and I was proved wrong
when he first went to prison in 62 and
again when he was tried again at 64 when
I witnessed that trial and had some
contact with him
but what happened then I think at that
point of course the speeches he made
part of which you've just quoted from
show absolutely clearly a man of
tremendous maturity and thoughtfulness
who had knew exactly what he was doing
when he in fact challenged the
government to send him to prison
but I think what happened was that his
chairmanship which he certainly had his
tremendous sense of his own image met up
with the actual challenge of the country
if you like he met his destiny at that
point and that was very very much like a
Churchill himself in 1940 when the man
who many people thought was who was
spoiling for a fight had a fight that
was worth spoiling for and found his
natural destiny as a war leader so when
Mandela was sentenced to prison he in
fact he knew what he was doing he knew
that he was as he said in that speech
that he was prepared to risk his life
for his principles and he knew that he
was undoubtedly going to have a pretty
rough time as a result but and I
remember in fact to my amusement when I
yeah when I was first starting my
biography I was talking to Mandela in
London during his state visit to Britain
in 1956 1996 which was a triumphal visit
and he just at that time being in
Trafalgar Square with a huge welcome
from every kind of person and then he
came to the Dorchester and we had a talk
together and he was in such amazingly
wonderfully generous form and so totally
at ease with himself I couldn't resist
asking him I said why were you was so
different when I first knew you why were
you so aloof and so so difficult to
communicate with and he smiled he said I
suppose I was defensive then and that
was very interesting to me that of
course he had a great deal to be
defensive about he'd been persecuted
humiliated and been exposed to all the
horrors of life in Johannesburg under
the apartheid state but at the same time
he had
fully found himself and that serenity
which you were fed to was I believe the
result of finding himself and knowing
exactly who he was and what he was doing
and that perhaps has interesting lessons
for politicians in general when he first
went to prison of course it was not
imagined by him or by most people
including myself that he would spend
anything like half a lifetime in prison
he thought he would probably spend about
five years that was probably what most
people thought and that appeared to be
then in terms of Africa at the time as
many of you will remember was thought to
be not an unusual event that other
African leaders revolutionaries would
spend a time in prison and then soon
afterwards came out as presidents that
happened to incur in Ghana it happened -
Kenyatta in Kenya and it happened in
other countries - I'm not saying that
was nationally in Mandela's mind but
certainly nobody amongst those prisoners
thought that they were going to spend
more than 25 years there but in fact of
course the prison period of 27 years was
not in there
far longer than they expected but I
believe was far more crucial to their
political development than anybody could
have guessed it was to me by far the
most interesting part of the research
and the story in my book because when
they went to prison they were no longer
part of a huge pageant of history like
most politicians with enormous numbers
of events around them and people coming
and going they were part of a very
intimate play they were part of a small
group of any 30 people in their
particular cell combination of cells
with a few warders in what was therefore
not only far more dramatic but far more
testing and much much more interesting
than any ordinary political life and to
me this is where the story of exceeds to
be one
south africa or about that particular
time but becomes a genuinely universal
story because how fascinating it is to
know how a group of people can survive
could strengthen themselves can interact
over that enormous a long period of time
to me the most thrilling part was
discovering not only grow Mandela's
letters of course which I had access to
from prison and letters from many people
to him in prison but also the prison
archives themselves which I got inside
which showed the prison reports of what
they thought about the prisoner
recording so clearly how in fact the
tables were turning how they were
constantly amazed how this awkward
prisoner could in fact get his own way
and how the warders were in many ways
becoming dependent upon him and how they
were failing
titli to rehabilitate him in their
phrase in a way that would make him
amenable to the ideas of the apartheid
government so this part of the story I
think is what really explains that
serenity that extraordinary sense of
peace that you'll find anybody finds
when they meet him and that ability to
relate to other people of every possible
kind it is the if you like the kind of
sophistication that would come from a
very careful psychoanalysis or the kind
of training that sometimes managers are
put when they become impossible to deal
with
when they have courses and sensitivity
training but that extended of a very
long period of time and anybody would
tell you that Mandela's ability to
relate to any kind of person and very
often to persuade them and to make them
understand him is something that they've
hardly ever found in a similar leader
but what was also very fascinating was
that in prison he was able
to more and more to communicate with the
africana warders many of whom came from
the least privileged and most miserable
backgrounds themselves he was able to
communicate with them was able to help
them in some cases to get them educated
in prison but also to understand the
workings of the Afrikaner mind and this
is a very interesting process I think
that because he saw these people every
day he was able to understand the nature
that own nationalism to see how the
Afrikaners had built up their own Dogma
their own dominating idea in some ways
similar to that of the Africans
themselves but with greater
vulnerability and he knew more about the
Afrikaners in those years in prison than
almost anybody had in his movement or
elsewhere had learnt in all the years
outside so that in fact the prison
became a kind of microcosm of South
Africa afterwards and much of the
philosophy and the technique of
reconciliation and forgiveness was
really formed by that relationship in
prison and as Mandela said to me his
great discovery in prison was realizing
that you could not regard the Afrikaners
or the warders as any kind of
homogeneous bloc that they were always
individual people and that you would
communicate with those individual people
as individuals can you hear
so they wait I'm sure where that's a
crime or how to convert shall I go back
a bit I'm sorry you in prison yes he
told me he made the discovery that you
could not regard waters or indeed other
groups of people as homogeneous as all
the same that they were individuals like
everybody else that you could argue
discuss with them as individuals and
indeed some of them some of the waters I
talked to were quite extraordinary
helpful to him
they button by passing messages by
getting special dispensations and by in
fact becoming virtually a part of that
movement often not a political reasons
the reasons a fear decency often of a
certain rebelliousness and sometimes of
just a common feeling and admiration for
the people that they were supposed to be
looking after but I think the most
crucial part of Mandela's education and
his lesson if you like for others was
his realization that in prison by
behaving with dignity by treating other
people with dignity and by remaining
absolutely true to your own principles
you could in fact ensure not only our
own integrity but extend that to others
it interested me that while he was in
prison he used to recite a rather old
fashioned Victorian poem by the paid w/e
Henley which I think began or part of it
was I am the master of my fate I am the
captain of my soul it's now in England
thought to be very old-fashioned but
that was what he would often recite in
the open in prison and of course this
was a large part of the key that the
fact that as a prisoner he could feel
himself to be his own master in the face
of every kind of
privation was of course what gave him
quite a considerable domination and
influence there were other people he
required there's arts of understanding
human nature which have I think evaded
many other politicians
well when Mandela emerged from prison
many people many many people like myself
were very apprehensive of what would
happen because the myth by that time had
become so enormous
the sculptures the streets the the the
paintings the reconstructions of him
were multiplying all the time the nobody
really knew what he was like the last
photograph of him was in 1965 taken in
prison and I know that in in London
there was a huge bust of him that was
unveiled I was there when it was
unveiled in 1985 showing him as a huge
thick-set figure with thick lips and
bull neck which still dominates the
Southbank outside the Festival Hall in
London was born their relation whatever
to what he really looked like it was a
rather Stalinist picture of a sort of
heroic leader not at all like his actual
presence which is always been rather at
rather sensitive about the delicate
features with none of that thick-set
arrangement but that was difficult of
they build up at the time of this
supposedly human superhuman figure I
talked him about that problem I said
were you not worried what would happen
when you came out of prison and he said
he'd thought about it a great deal
because of course at that stage he read
he could read a lot of newspapers and he
could see them see films and sometimes
television said that he knew exactly the
build-up was going on outside and he
told me for that reason he was
determined that when he came out he
would show himself to be
a purse ordinary person with ordinary
weaknesses he was determined to avoid
the kind of personality cult which of
course it afflicted many other African
countries the idea that chroma or nobody
else was superhuman and he took great
pains he said to make sure in those
first weeks that he was perfectly
ordinary and I remember very vividly
getting to see him a week after he came
out of jail because I was lucky enough
to be in South Africa at the time and
there he was in the same house where I
had last seen him in Soweto same small
little matchbox ice very overcrowded
surrounded by people waiting to see him
with his wife then wife Winnie acting
apparently as the perfect housewife and
helpmeet rather misleadingly
but that was part of his determination
to appear to be and in fact to be a
human being with ordinary weaknesses but
when he did emerge from prison he did
undoubtedly have a particular kind of
mastery of politics which is I think the
real secret of his leadership many
people talk to him then of course as a
saint and that became often the label
and when she described he always told me
that he disliked very much being called
a saint he didn't mind being called a
sinner who keeps on try but the fact was
of course that he was a master
politician in the best sense of that
term in the sense of being always
concerned with the long term and having
a very clear idea of what he was trying
to achieve and of seeing the country's
future as being the overriding objective
and it was this that made him determined
on his policy
of reconciliation and forgiveness well
in a sense of course that was saintly it
might appear to be saintly to be able to
go to see our former persecutors
including his prosecutor in his last
trial they would have dr. Fairport the
most intransigent prime minister and
many other pretty horrendous people to
give you able to get to see them and to
shake hands with them and have tea with
them and so on
that does that many of us seem quite
saintly but whether or not it was saint
it was also a very shrewd politically
because by forgiving them individually
he was in fact helping to disarm and to
defuse the Afrikaner white resentment
against him and their coming a black
majority and at the same time he was
undoubtedly acquiring his own moral
authority so to distinguish between the
saint and the master politician is not
always easy and certainly is the man who
rat ran his own department tell me that
he was always wondering whether he was a
saint or Machiavelli but of course there
comes a point whether to become not
necessarily is so different when you
accept that the ultimate objective is to
save your country and to unify people in
the same sense of purpose
and of course behind that wonderfully
soft and welcoming style he remained a
very tough
even ruthless negotiator it was
interesting to see how he was able to
mislead somebody like de Klerk in
there's long negotiations before he
became president de Klerk was I think
too easily convinced that Mandela was a
soft touch because of his charm and his
courtesy and it made the moments when
Mandela suddenly burst out with fury
against a clerk all the more effective
what always exasperated Mandela as he
said to me above all was when the
moments when he felt that his dignity
and therefore the African dignity was
being offended it was that issue above
all it was when people were passion
izing him or when they were assuming him
to have some different status that would
always ensure that he would break
through that otherwise supremely ketches
behavior and in fact of course in prison
he had been steeled and hardened as one
of his colleagues said by that
experience as well as becoming much more
understanding of other people and I
suppose that is perhaps the most
powerful combination for a leader is to
have that combination of being able to
understand people to relate to them but
to be absolutely determined on the
crucial issues not to give way and to
get your own way it was of course
amazing to many people when Mandela came
out of prison to see how extraordinary
adept he was as a politician in the PLA
technical sense
I used to often to see him working the
room or with many other people
in a situation like that of many other
leaders like President Clinton for
instance you're seeing them with such
extraordinary ability to say the right
person think the right person to
remember names to understand exactly how
to get people to support you he appeared
in many ways to be the ultimate modern
politician in that sense and having seen
having never seen television in South
Africa for most of his time in prison
the Cosa Africa didn't allow television
to 1976 because they were worried about
its impact on the blacks it was a
fascinating to see how he became a
natural television performer people said
that he was almost the ultimate
postmodern politician with such
extraordinary gifts but I think that was
not true I think in fact that ability to
relate to people that understanding of
persuasion came partly from his prison
experience but also from his experience
as a child when he was being looked
after by the Guardian by the local chief
and he watched that chief with his own
tribesmen determined to keep them
together to persuade them and to let
them have their say it was rule like a
pre-modern experience more like that of
the old monarchies than of the modern
boot getters well the question remains I
think for anybody who's watched Mandana
including those who've known him better
than I have exactly how that balance is
between the saint and the Machiavelli
exactly how much of him is calculating
able to manipulate able to get people on
his side like a master politician how
much of it is an ultimate fundamental
goodness of character which is able to
see ahead
and to understand what people really
want
of course Machiavelli himself was not
setting up to be the prophet of sinister
schemes he was simply describing the art
of being a great Prince and I could
argue that that is what in the end
Mandela has become because his star was
in many ways much more monarchic than it
was Republican or purely democratic
there he always understood what the
importance of democracy but if you look
back at this extraordinary development I
think what the real legacy was and this
is my concluding point it was the
ability of Mandela to set a pattern of
multiracialism and of genuine equality
of understanding and treatment between
the races and what's so fascinating
about his biography is to see how he
developed from his interest his loyalty
to his local tribe in the Eastern Cape
and his sense of his own tribal history
he developed from that into the
understanding of Johannesburg and other
people other blacks in Johannesburg as a
leader of the African people in general
and then from that into realizing that
the whites Indians and colored people
were also part of that country and that
they must be part of that single unity
it was in passing and ironical fact that
he was taught that the people who most
made him realize the importance of that
were the Communists it was a time when
the other white parties accepted no
black members at all into the Communist
Party had black members and thus had a
genuine multiracial approach but in
prison I think he took that much further
he took that a
of the Equality of the non racialism
South Africa to a stage when it was hard
to distinguish in his attitude between
his own black African people and Indians
and others the fact that he was in the
same prison cells of 30 people there
were Indians and coloreds who he became
amongst his very closest friends was
part of that development I believe and
what I think today is most remarkable
about South Africa is that that
multiracialism has become established as
the pattern both of government and
increasingly of society that's what
distinguishes it from most of the rest
of Africa and that what that is what
gives
Mandela such a tremendously important
inference in the rest of the world it's
the extension if you like of his concept
of dignity from his purely African
context into humankind in general and
it's interesting in watching him to see
how his attitude to people does not
appear to change at all whoever it is
that he's talking to it's a rather
interesting experience to watch so I
believe that in that rather
extraordinary story that I've had the
privilege to try to record and to give
as it were a flesh and blood what is
most fascinating I think in that whole
development is to see the progress from
there from the tribe the relatively
small tribe into the whole world scene
which has given him that particular
understanding and if that is
Machiavellian then thank God for
Machiavelli maker
we're going to take questions if you'd
like to go to either a microphone and
identify yourself and do you want to
stand here in speaking of the mythology
of leadership it brings to mind how many
women behind those very strong powerful
men but you wouldn't mention or hadn't
mentioned anything about his wife and
I'm wondering what that relationship
might have been because their
philosophies must have been different
well I'm glad you raised that question
because I said I was any gravity because
I of course I knew all three of his
wives and that part of the story in my
book it's the most fascinating to me
subplot there is and at one point I have
to say it was a it was a rather
embarrassing a subplot because when I
started the book the Mandela's marital
situation with Winnie Mandela was in
ruins and he was a very lonely man and
it was a very unhappy story to end with
and for me as a bar graph er it was a
kind of miracle and graça Machel
appeared on the scene and they had fair
extraordinary in effect of a rare
genuine love affair but what was
interesting is I think you imply was
that he always had a he was always
attracted by strong with him he was
attracted by women in general I mean he
was he liked women in
very relaxed way and a lot of women
amongst his closest advisors or were but
he was particularly interested in strong
women I think myself that this was
linked oddly to his father's polygamy
his father had four wives and he as a
child was the only boy child at home and
spent very very happy times with each of
his mothers as he called them and this
gave him a sense of great security sense
of security and confidence in their love
but at the same time I think made it
very much easier for him to communicate
very very easily with women which is
again not always true of politicians he
hears immediate entourage particularly
as president they included some very
strong women and graça Machel has
herself his third wife who gave me some
of the best interesting interviews in my
book it was of course used to being a
president's wife because she had been
married the president of Mozambique and
was already then a politician in her
right and may yet eventually be
president of Mozambique herself well
that is again unusual to have that
degree of a strong very strong political
support from your wife and from women in
general the case of Winnie is of course
it's a tremendously interesting story I
first knew her in the 60s and I got on
air very well in the mid 80s when I used
to correspond and bring her up before as
well I decided did not realize then that
she'd gone round the bend to put it
bluntly but she will course was a very
strong woman
and very difficult to control he said in
prison that he thought he was there any
person who could control her and for
that reason was guilt-ridden that he was
not in the position to do so I think
even before he went to prison he
realized that she desperately needed a
very very strong man to make sure she
did not get off the rails but that story
is well enough now the only point I
would like to make about Winnie is that
all there she is a very dangerous woman
and has done some very terrible things
the the popular reports of her I think
rather make the story less interesting I
believe it is they present Winnie rather
as a kind of horror horror movie
character and some of her acts do belong
in that jar but the story is more moving
more interesting than that I think it's
more like Antony Cleopatra like I had
very long talks with her too
and it's I think it's possible without
in any way approving of the of the the
worst thing she did it is possible to
have some kind of sympathy with her of
the kind the Shakespeare could display
towards his chechik heroines ie that she
belonged to the world of tragedy rather
than of horror IRA now I haven't for the
answered your question but that's maybe
a clue
do you feel that you mentioned that
Mandela's relationships with people
don't generally change but do you find
especially since his release that
there's been a divergent both divergence
both philosophically and in personal
relationships between he and his prison
inmates such as go on and Becky sue Sulu
Maharaj and others does he gain more
towards a man of the 90s and a new-style
politician why they have stayed in the
course and has that affected their
relationship between those who he spent
the 27 years with well it is very
interesting that I mean one of the most
interesting documents I was able to see
was the accounts of the arguments he had
with his left-wing colleagues in in
prison in Robben Island which were
recorded and which were much fiercer
than has been generally knowledged and
those arguments had a very important
consequence later on it is true of
course that the the prisoners the people
have been through prison when they came
out of prison had a very different
experience from the exiles or indeed
from the freedom fighters in the field
from the guerrilla fighters and that
there was some tension after they all
came back to South Africa between those
different groups but there was also the
tension that had come out very openly
inside Robben Island itself and that
part of the story is tremendously
interesting particularly with governor
Baker who you mentioned governor must
explain is the was probably the most
effective Marxist in prison very strong
character father of the present
president there not at all sharing his
views now and that argument between what
they call in prison they call him the
communist versus the Nationalists well
there Mandela wasn't nationalist he was
described as that in the sense that he
didn't regard the communists as being as
it were preeminent
he did not want the NSE to be dominated
by the Communists but there that tension
was very great and of course it became
greater in the period before and
mutually before Mandela's release when
it became clear that Mandela was having
secret talks with government
representatives which the left wingers
the Communists particularly suspected
were selling out their cause well it
wasn't the sellout in the sense they
said it was but of course it is true
that many communists wanted South Africa
to go through what they call a rolling
revolution which would in effect reduce
the country to a state of chaos when the
would then be an effective seizure of
power to use their phrase whereas
Mandela was convinced that the cost of
such a civil war would be catastrophic
in terms of human life that would lead
fragmented country so that tension was
very considerable and beneath the
arguments today which remain of course
that memory of the Robben Island
experience remains very strong but still
rather discreetly discussed and I was
lucky to be able to break through part
of that story of course as you imply
there were many other divisions between
prisoners and other sectors of the
opposition at that time
I hope you'll forgive my ignorance but I
get by implication that his leadership
has helped to overcome a multiracial
racial problem the question is is his
victory complete does he think so can
the pattern of leadership be applied in
other cases memory serves George Bernard
Shaw said the Irish haven't forgotten
after 400 years you have Bosnia and so
on so the implication of a pattern of
leadership might give hope elsewhere I
don't know well it's it is a very it's a
crucial question what I'm saying yes
it's a crucial question listen did I
have talked to the beds of Mandela and
to the negotiators of the settlement in
South Africa about the the Northern
Irish parallel and they they have as
some of the negotiators have been to
Northern Ireland and both sides have
been out of South Africa sadly when the
two sides came out of South Africa they
wouldn't agree to sit in the same room -
yeah Mandela talked they had to have two
separate rooms which suggests your play
implied pessimism as has good grounds
but I was interested that Cinerama Pozzo
who was the best probably the most
effective negotiator in the settlement
he said to me that part of the secret of
the successful negotiations was the
ability of the African side to
understand to empathize with the
sufferings of the Afrikaners of the
other side and it was at the moment when
the Afrikaners realized that their
opponents or their
the other side of the negotiation could
understand that own grievances there was
a tremendous breakthrough that was part
of the secret I think at the same time
there was the the Ross Ice pairs a sense
of realism that existed in South Africa
about the alternative the realization
that without a settlement the future
would be unthinkable or appalling so I
think myself my own feeling is that the
in Northern Ireland
neither side have yet reached the stage
when they can empathize for the other
and there is a tradition of vengeance
and hatred which is not yet been
overcome but there is another belief
that that vengeance is not not very deep
in that African way of thinking and that
may also be true but I think like as I
think you do that that lesson is not
easily applicable to all other countries
or in the Balkans I think the cross the
Balkan crisis that had any emerged
rather later but that may be even harder
to resolve I was wondering if you feel
that Mandela himself now has any
interest or willingness or desire to
evolve himself in other situations where
he might serve as sort of a mediator
I was thinking specifically of the
problems in Haiti Haiti's us but country
and they have all kinds of poverty and
so forth and I've always thought that if
Mandela were interested in coming to
Haiti and spending some time with the
different factions he might serve as
someone who could be looked at and could
be followed whose advice and so forth
might to try to hope to resolve some of
the
the differences does he himself her his
Eastfield that he's sort of dead his
saying and he's ready to retire now sit
back or would he be interested in doing
something you know sort of an active way
well it's I would say god I can't speak
for him but yeah I know he has he has
been asked to join either draw another
group so occasionally to help to resolve
questions he has said since he sees the
president or in the last few months in a
way that he doesn't want to be involved
in mediation but I didn't think that
necessarily is true I think he may he
may find himself involved I think the
experience for the Qaddafi was
interesting particularly in this country
of course it was interesting because
there whatever you may think of Qaddafi
I believe myself that Mandela performed
a quite a useful function particularly
in bringing the suspect to trial but
also I think in terms of African
diplomacy and bringing Qaddafi into the
it's being exposed to the rest of Africa
which he out till then had played a role
in but in a way I think irresponsible
and mischievous way what was interesting
I did have quite long talks with the
negotiator as well as with Mandela about
the Qaddafi case what was interesting to
me was that it was cleared that Mandela
was the only person who was trusted by
all sides in that negotiation qaddafi'd
trust him completely and virtually said
at the end look I'm I'm not sure without
a right thing but if you say that I am
in handing ever the prisoners in effect
to your charge then I will do it
it was interesting there particularly
because Mandela was able to do something
that the UN could not
because Gaddafi didn't good not to trust
the UN and Qaddafi thought the UN was
too influenced by by the United States
particularly whereas Mandela had this
completely independent presence and was
a kind of one-man UN which itself is
quite interesting I think in terms of
reflection of international diplomacy
and I think first and that ability to
have to obtain trust even if it's the
trust of some very dangerous operators
like Castro Qaddafi does remain a
tremendously important factor in
international diplomacy
Sayre personally I rather hope that he
does find himself involved in in in
further operations of that kind either
individually or I know he has been asked
to join groups of eminent people who
have been trying to further
troubleshooting got is an Mandela
Foundation with the group of trusted
colleagues around him and their that
they have some kind of office and
organization I would guess they have
quite a lot of bridges made to them of
various kinds and we have to take care
to sort out the serious of the unserious
but my own my own guess is that that may
evolve into a group that may be made use
of them at this moment Mandela is that I
believe in Aspen Colorado taking part in
some conference which is not altogether
separate from what we're discussing but
not not as part of
group so he's his interests in the
international scene remain very great
and of course as a matter of sensible
precaution he wants to avoid interfering
with South African politics Sarah makes
and more inclined to interfere with
other people's politics put it that way
but I would would be surprised if he
were not to become involved in in the
more criticals in Indonesia oh you must
remember he did pay this interesting
role in bringing pressure to bear for
the release of Kuzma are they mr.
Murray's leader who he felt he made sure
that he could see this time of Suharto
and had quite a great admiration for him
sir he has he's rather enjoyed looking
at other situations but of course it's
high risk mr. Samson
my name is Russell mo Khyber I edit a
publication called corporate crime
reporter here in Washington DC and I
know that your previous books in some of
your previous books you've dealt with
the excesses of corporate capitalism in
flipping through your book I noticed
that there's been some criticism of
Mandela as being too cozy with big
business in South Africa and you quote a
Deputy Minister as telling a group of
black businessmen not to be shy about
becoming filthy rich and I was wondering
if you could elaborate a little bit on
Mandela's view of business throughout
his career and how Mandela South Africa
is dealing with big business
corporations well it is an extraordinary
story
I asked Mandela once when what contact
she had with businessmen before he went
to jail and of course even before that
it's before 1962
when he was already after all quite well
known and he said one just one contact
and that was when he went to see how
open
was then the most powerful businessman
the chairman of anglo-american if some
money of some help with transport the
ferry conference and often either tell
me the detailed Mandela that he felt he
couldn't give money to the ANC because
he didn't think that they were going to
win out over the other party the PSC
which had just been formed which was an
interesting misjudgment just enough I
saw often I'm a few weeks after Mandela
tell me that and he corroborated fully
well the story themselves now I say that
simply to share how little mandela was
had any contact with business at all and
as he said to me his experience up till
that point had been entirely from the
other side from from trade unions or
from black workers but i think when he
came out my own feeling is that he could
be rather naive about about big business
i think as he said to me he he had to
feel grateful to them but because
whenever he asked them for anything in
terms of money for clinics or for
schools or anything and specific
projects which was always his particular
concern they always gave him what he
asked for
so how could he not appreciate that i
think many of his colleagues and i would
share their concern feel that that was a
rather a naive view of big business that
you can't necessarily see them in terms
of specific projects and i think in
other ways they were often rather
exploiting positions and sometimes not
altogether honest in the way they
presented it specifically i think the
the pressure for South Africa under
Mandela's presidency to relax all
exchange controls and to allow the free
flow of capital and to dismantle all
their previous structure on the basis
that was the only way you would attract
large sums of capital and I think that
was not all that sensible advice person
because the players of capital as we
know are so rapid and so dangerous for a
developing country that you had to be
fairly careful about that and of course
very little capital has actually flown
into South Africa anyway so you could
say that he was rather misled on that on
those grounds but to get back to your
question I think I think in his
presidency
Mandana he perhaps relied a bit too much
on the advice of big business people he
acquired a great respect for business
leaders many of them find people one or
two of them I think not quite so fine
and of course it is a situation in which
people can exploit the position and have
sometimes not being all together
construct him in their suggestions but I
argued about this with him and he
strongly rejected my belief that he had
been naive and said that they had after
all given him what he'd asked for was
their backlash to the kind of statement
that the trade minister made to
encourage black businessmen to be not to
be shy to become filthy rich yes I'm
glad to say there was that's that remark
that was made about I think a junior
minister I think the filthy-rich remark
which was a very silly thing to say did
lead to debate in which I think Mandela
did not in so many words but did totally
dissociate himself from it certainly
Thabo Mbeki did but of course that did
reflect the the problem of what was an
incredibly rapid transition I mean the
the fact that in just a matter of a very
few years people who had had no access
to capital whatever
and their opportunity to Al Malley had
often been co-opted often rather
deliberately sent as well as cynically
into positions where they could make
quite a lot of money quickly this could
create considerable confusion about the
values of money and being filthy rich
and that remains as it is in any young
country in fact a considerable problem
it's coming to the question of
leadership the new leadership in South
Africa could you comment a little bit on
how Mandela made this decision or was
involved in this decision to have Thabo
Mbeki as the foot as the next president
as opposed to someone like Cyril
Ramaphosa and how perhaps that links
into the question of Machiavelli and the
so certainly the perception that Thabo
Mbeki doesn't have a lot of the
characteristics you've been dwelling on
Madiba having picked up in his prison
years for example and at the same time
the fact that perhaps many of his some
of the criticism of him as a leader has
been his inability to be tough on crime
and corruption for example and what your
view is then of the next few years of
leadership and the process of getting
there and how these factors played into
that broad question but some comments
would be appreciated a lot of questions
well the the election of tomandbecky he
did he tell me with surprising candor
what his attitude was there because what
he said was that he did have some
worries about Thabo Mbeki as when he was
first made deputy president which of
course meant very likely that he would
become the successor president as he did
and Mandela said that he had won a
particularly that the Tavor was like
many of the other African it was of
course
and that would increase the worries that
the government was dominated by a single
tribal group whereas of course sir Rama
purrs oh who was that main rival came
from a small tribe from the vendor and
would thus could perhaps play more
equalizing row between the other tribes
and he then Mandela went on to say that
while he had reservations in fact it was
decided not by him it was decided by the
group of ANC leaders and leaders of the
trade unions and of the Communist Party
and there's all three favored
tomandbecky so he bodied he abided by
the decision and he used the phrase to
me without making my own views known he
didn't nationally say that he was
against it but that phrase was
significant that he didn't make his own
views now and I wouldn't that I would
assume that his own view was that it
should not be tougher Becky he did make
a rather curious coded remark about
congratulating Becky on having been
elected president of the ANC which he
was then but then saying pointing out
the dangers are being elected unopposed
and how you could if you were unopposed
you could get into the habit of
surrounding ourselves with cronies of
residency argument and of generally
preferring to do things for the close
group of friends and some people thought
this was a coded warning to Mbeki who
had been accused of surrounding himself
as cronies and I think it probably was
that but having said that I think since
that time Mandela was gave no indication
of concern and I was at the inauguration
in July which was itself a remarkable
event I mean the
smoothness of that succession very few
people mother to comment on it because
it was said smooth was the in a sense
you were saying the ultimate tribute to
metallic achievement that nobody
expected any problems with that
succession and there were none there was
some raillery there were some jokes
between mandela and baekje which might
suggest a certain tension but they were
done in such good humour there was
difficult to say that but just to skip
your other questions and to say to go to
the future and the question of crime
because often people link theirs to the
crime problem and I've cross discussed
this with Mandela is a much broader
problem I think of many people are
prepared to accept what Mandela does get
very annoyed by still is people who only
became interested in the crime problem
when it spilled over into the white
world because the black crime in black
particularly in fact Johannesburg was
always horrendous one of the first
article I ever wrote about South Africa
in 1951 for the magazine drum before
Black Friday's took over was a chroma an
article about crime on the reef sharing
and it had the worst crime record of any
country in the world that was black
Janis berg and most of the crime was of
course in the black townships it was
only when that crime began to impact on
the white suburbs that this enormous
publicity occurred of course crime has
got worse but not as much worse as
people assume and the problem in the
meantime is far more difficult I believe
to resolve than people fully recognized
the problem of corrupt police force is
probably the worst part which is common
to say Russia or Latin American
countries which have been dictatorships
you have the same pattern when you have
an autocratic regime the police are
corrupt they're badly paid they're used
to torture and interrogation rather than
catching criminals and
soon as you liberalize criminals have a
wonderful opportunity to to rush into
the country and to organize syndicates
because the police are so weakened and
the laws liberalized in a way that makes
it harder to get heard of them well I
think myself that baekje is probably
more realistic about this than than
Mandela was I think Mandela you I think
you've said or implied that Mandela was
too weak on that question and I think
that may be true baekje is showing signs
of being tougher but I think a lot of
what is happening one of the most
crucial things that are happening in
fact behind the scenes and include
International Cooperation which may be
the most important part of the story I
know for instance that in Bakke his
talks with Al Gore here they have this
own special bilateral group the question
of getting support from the FBI and for
the technology and systems that go with
it has been very important part of the
agenda and the British also have been
helping there because of course part of
the large part of the crime is really
from big syndicates which are very
difficult to get a hold of and often
linked to international groups anywhere
I'm not remembered making excuses and
the crime problem I think there were
late in addressing but my and my own
belief is that Becky I know it's the
forefront of his mind and I think he may
well be more effective than Mandela was
side view on as I understand it and
correct me if I'm wrong you're on the
advisory board of the independent
newspaper group and I am interested to
know what you believe the media's role
to be in respect of crime because I
would agree that the I would I believe
that the crime is certainly over it's a
it's a major problem but that it's it
has a higher profile globally which has
a major impact on fun investment in to
South Africa and I think the media both
locally in South Africa and globally has
a has an important role in that respect
and and what is your view on that I
absolutely agree I think that if in
every country revealed their crime rate
in the way that the South African papers
do many other countries would appear to
be immensely dangerous and of course by
publicizing crime in London or New York
or Washington indeed you could make them
sound absolutely impossible to to live
in of course it is true that
Johannesburg does have a higher crime
rate than any other city in the world at
the moment but as you imply that the
publicity given to it is often quite
misleading but it's very difficult to
prevent that I think I think in many
cases there's the citizen despair for
instance which was in Johannesburg
probably the most obsessed with the
crime has recently dropped that line
linked perhaps to change of ownership
and given doesn't give quite the same
obsessive coverage but as we know crime
is a good story for journalists and it's
particularly good story
unfortunately for white journalists who
want to share that things have got much
worse
and who are more interested in crime
against whites than crime against blacks
and that is remains a great political
problem that by not facing up to the
past history of crime you are giving a
very misleading picture of what's
happened today mr. Sampson thank you
very much for joining us this evening
and sharing your experiences and also
your new book on behalf of the National
Press Club we have a token of our
appreciation it's the National Press
Club mud and all honored guests and
speakers receive that are kings and
heads of states and and everyone so
thank you very much for joining us this
evening I know that some people have
some books that they would like signed
maybe what we could do is you know bring
the books up front here and mr. Tsai